>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Ellen Oh: Welcome to the first
Walter D. Meyers Award Ceremony
for Outstanding Children's
Literature.
My name is Ellen Oh, and I am
honored to be the President and CEO
of We Need Diverse Books.
[ Cheering ]
[ Applause ]
Although the We Need Diverse
Books organization is less
than two years old, the idea
behind it is not a new one.
There have been many
advocates championing the need
for diverse books in children's
literature for decades.
We walk in the footsteps of giants.
All that we do builds upon the
life work of authors, teachers,
librarians, editors, advocates,
many of whom are sitting
right here in this room.
But it was Mr. Myers
last [inaudible] piece
in the New York Times where other
people of color in children's books
that became the catalyst for the
We Need Diverse Books campaign.
A rallying cry that brought together
advocates from all over the country.
And the world responded with
a loud and collective roar
that could not be ignored.
I am so honored to be here today
to celebrate Mr. Myers legacy
by recognizing a new generation of
outstanding authors and their books.
And I am proud and
grateful to have Mrs. Myers
and Christopher Myers here to be
a part of this momentous event.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
Also with us today are some
of the important people
in Water Dean Myers life,
like Miriam Altshuler,
his long time agent and his editors
FBA, Medina Griffin [phonetic],
Andrea Davis Pigmey [phonetic],
and Rosemary Brosman [phonetic],
and Barbara Marcus [phonetic],
who most recently published
his Random House books
and was his marketer over
his scholastic books, too.
So, thank you for coming
to Washington,
D.C. also to celebrate with us.
And, of course, I have to
say that we wouldn't be
in this beautiful room if it wasn't
for our friends here at the Library
of Congress, all the wonderful
staff at the Young Reader's Center
and the Center for the Book,
most particularly, John Cole,
Karen Jaffey [phonetic], and
Kaheem Mohammad [phonetic].
Now, I have the great
pleasure of introducing you
to the acting Librarian
of Congress, David Mao.
David Mao oversees
the entire library
and its various service units to
ensure that the library service
to Congress and the American
people are provided effectively.
He previously served as
deputy Librarian of Congress
and the 23rd law Librarian
of Congress, too.
So, please welcome David Mao.
>> David Mao: Thank
you so much, Ellen,
and good morning to all of you.
Welcome to the Library of Congress.
I'm very happy to be able to be here
for this very special
occasion today.
Our nation's diversity, of course,
is one of the greatest
strengths that we have here.
And so I think that diversity
should be reflected in all
of the books that our children read.
Now, the Library of Congress
we're, as you probably know,
the world's largest
library and we have what we
like to call our Universal
Collection.
And it's universal in that
we not only have books,
but we have a variety of other
materials, including films,
photographs, manuscripts, sound
recordings, just to name a few.
In our children's collection, alone,
we have more than 500,000 children's
books and other related items.
Now, these books are on
every subject imaginable.
And we welcome visitors to
our Young Reader's Center
so that they can touch, read,
and really enjoy these materials.
And so I'm really delighted today
that the Young Reader's Center,
which is administered by
the Library Congress Center
for the Book is a sponsor
for this event.
And you heard of our very
wonderful, Dr. John Cole,
who has led the Library
Congress Center for the Book
for very many, many years.
And so thank you, John, for
making arrangements for this.
Now, since 2008 the Librarian
of Congress has also appointed
and offered to serve as the
Library's national ambassador
for young people's literature.
And this person, he or she,
travels around the country promoting
literacy and raising awareness
of its impact on the education
and the development and betterment
of the lives of young people.
So, we are very, very fortunate
to have Walter Dean Myers serve
as that ambassador
from 2012 to 2013.
His platform was, Reading
Is Not Optional.
And so this newly established Walter
Award highlights the importance
of publishing books
in which children
of all backgrounds
can see themselves
and honor Walter's
commitment to literacy.
And we're also very delighted
that we can have our very first
ambassador with us, Jon Scleszka,
who is sitting here in
the front row to be here
to celebrate this important award.
I want to thank We Need
Diverse Books for its work
in promoting the best
in children's literature
and for recognizing Walter
Dean Myers for his devotion
to writing books that enrich
the lives of young people
and for his outreach to
a population at risk.
And it's now my pleasure to
introduce Dhonielle Clayton,
Chief Operating Officer
of We Need Diverse Books.
She's the co-chair of the
Walter Award judge's panel.
Dhonielle, who is an author herself,
is also co-founder of Cake Literary,
a boutique book development company.
So, please join me in
welcoming Dhonielle Clayton.
[ Applause ]
>> Dhonielle Clayton: I'm
absolutely thrilled to be here today
with my co-chair, Kathy Weinberg
[phonetic] representing the
inaugural Walter Award
judging committee.
The 11 member committee
had the pleasure
of reading young adult novels
that followed characters
through perilous worlds,
their first heartbreaks,
and the search for
their true selves.
But three submissions stood out.
It's hard to get 11 people
to agree on anything,
but these three special
books kind of rose to the top
and were unmistakable in
their emotional resonance.
As the committee discussed
these books, I also test them
out in my own library
with my students.
I gave them copies, especially
to my most spirited ones,
the ones that say,
"Oh, I hate to read."
And then something magical happened,
they started to get in trouble
in class because they
wouldn't stop reading
and transition to class work.
They had fallen into
these three books
and I think that's the
most important quality.
And the judges got it right.
And when I saw them reading
those books, I knew that
and I knew our committee
was on the right path.
And someone who knows kids
really well that I want
to introduce is Jon Scleszka.
He's the first ever
national ambassador
for young people's literature
by the Librarian of Congress
and the Children's Book Council.
As the ambassador, Scleszka toured
the country to raise awareness
about the importance of
children's literature
and his books were also stolen
in droves from my library.
So, I think he's the most
important person to come
up here and talk about it.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Jon Scleszka: Wow!
I don't think I've ever had
that compliment before,
but I'll take that.
[ Laughter ]
Walter told me when I first met him,
maybe it wasn't the first time
I met him, but it's this thing
that just hit me like a
lightning bolt when I met Walter,
and he said what became the
end of his essay in the times.
It is, "We need to do work."
And that thing just felt
like it got chiseled
in my soul when he told it to me.
It was a moment that I think has
got us where we are right now,
which is the most exciting thing.
'Cause Walter was a guy who
was not that much of a talker.
I mean, he could do the talk, but
I loved him for being the doer.
He was the guy who
actually did things.
He's the guy who changed
my life when we talked
about being the ambassador,
going places.
And we did the usual places like
to be on T.V. with Martha Stewart,
maybe not such a great thing.
A little entertaining,
but Walter said,
"You know where we're
supposed to be?
In schools, they never
see an author.
We're supposed to be
in the prisons."
And he would go to those places.
He got me into those places.
And it just shook me.
It was like, these are both like
the most inspirational places
and the most heartbreaking
all rolled into one.
And it's the work we're doing
right now, which is so exciting
because we're making a difference.
And this is the difference
we need to make.
I kind of love that this
is Walter still living.
This is him right now, right here.
How great is the [inaudible]?
Just name him Walter.
When I heard that I said, "Oh,
man, give me some of that."
[ Laughter ]
And I know that he influenced
the lives of these guys.
I know when Jason and
Brendan had been around,
they did the same thing.
They've been into prisons here.
They've been into the
schools that never see us.
And we're that possibility
just by walking in.
And I think that's what
Diverse Books is going to be all
about in the best way,
despite what we're reading
in the newspapers everyday
about some people's hand size.
Please, dear God, let's not --
I'm sorry I even mentioned that.
Let's not think about that ever.
Too late, I just planted that.
[ Laughter ]
That's bad.
But we got to go better.
We gotta go positive.
It's up to us to change things.
We are the leaders now.
We'll show people how it's done.
We'll all follow what
Walter told us to do.
So, I just want to
leave you with that.
Let's hear from the winners here.
Congratulations you guys.
[ Applause ]
This is so exciting.
And I'll just leave you with that.
We need to do work.
Let's do that.
All right, who gets to talk next?
Let's send somebody else over here.
John Cole, do we need
to hear from you?
Chris. How about some from Chris?
[ Cheering ]
>> Christopher Myers:
How are you guys doing?
So, what does it mean
then to do the work?
I'll try to get off
here soon because I want
to see the [inaudible] concept.
[ Laughter ]
What does it mean to do the work?
You know, you're in this place,
this institution, it's so beautiful,
it's so peaceful, as
so many libraries are.
These like places of peacefulness.
And I've spent years
trying to think, "Well,
why are libraries so
calm in that way?"
And I realized that it's because
on all the shelves, in every book,
is a fight, that there's
an argument being had.
And really it's got
to be peaceful in here
because we are surrounded
by arguments.
We are surrounded by fights.
And those fights are a gift to us.
These are the fights that
our nation was built on.
This kind of -- have you ever
read the Federalist papers?
You see these intense arguments as
to how we should know the nation.
Our nation is built on fights.
So, don't, for a moment, see
yourself in this beautiful,
beautiful, peaceful institution,
but imagine yourself on fight night.
[ Laughter ]
Imagine yourself in
a room full of fans
and blood thirsty savage wanters,
people who want to see blood.
Because this is who we are
amongst, we are fighters.
Everybody here in this room
is a fighter of some sort.
Imagine the weigh-in,
imagine the crowd,
imagine my father who
loved a good fight.
When we fight, we're
asking questions.
We're asking important questions.
And this is not a straw dog
fight of imagined enemies.
No, we have real questions and real
respected opponents that we want
to have discussions with,
that we want to engage with.
We want to try to change
minds and hearts.
That's what a real fight is about.
And that's what every
one of these authors,
every one of these librarians,
every one of these teachers,
every one of these publishers,
this is what we do, we fight.
We fight for things we believe in.
We ask questions.
We ask, "What does it mean to be
behind barbed wire at Manzanar?"
"What does it mean to
perform at a Yiddish theatre
in the lower east side and
listen to jazz records at night?"
We ask, "What does it mean
to protest in Ferguson?"
That's what the work
that John was mentioning.
That's what it looks like.
It looks like these fights.
What does it mean to be in a tiny
boat as it comes up on the shore
on the beginning of the new
life in the United States?
What does it mean to hear the first
bricks being thrown a stonewall
and hear your name in
the crash of the glass?
We are fighters here.
And this is where the fights
happen in our exchange of ideas,
in the discussions that we have.
And so whether you're fighting
an acquisitions committee to say,
"This book needs to be published."
Whether you're fighting to
get books into the hands
of children and you're a librarian.
Whether you're WNDB fighting to
have more fights in the world
to have access to the
arena of fighting.
Whether you're an author of
fighting a stack of words
to get in the right order.
I know a little bit about fights.
I watched dad fight.
I fight. And I'm so excited to be
part of this fight, this discussion.
And I'm excited to
honor the fighters
that have fought a good
fight in these books.
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah, so let's get that going.
The first person we would like
to honor is Margarita Engle.
You talk about a fight.
You talk about wings.
You talk about a fight
of two cultures.
Cultures fighting inside us and
how much that gives us, that fight,
that battle inside us, which is, in
the end, the most important fight.
You have Cuba.
You have the United States.
You have the -- what could
be imagined as a fight,
but it's really a liberation
because all of these discussions
in the end yield liberation
for us all.
And so, Margarita Engle, for
"Enchanted Air: Two Cultures,
Two Wings, a Memoir", thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Margarita Engle: Thank you.
Gracias. Gracias por Dios.
I am so incredibly grateful
to We Need Diverse Books.
Sorry. I'm not -- I'm down here.
I forgot. I forgot I was
here in the race of giants.
[ Laughter ]
The fight of giants.
Yes. I'm so incredibly grateful.
The Walter Award Committee, my
editor, Rayka Simonson [phonetic],
Justin Chanda, Candice
Green, McManus
and the whole [inaudible] Simon and
Schuster publishing team, thank you,
and to the Library of
Congress for hosting us.
In his how to book, "Just Write",
Walter Dean Myers instructed,
"Be brave."
Writing a memoir does
require courage
because childhood memories
can be excruciating.
And bringing them back
to life is terrifying.
Showing them to strangers
is especially intimidating.
Showing them to family
members is even scarier.
That is precisely why
this honor means so much
because being misunderstood
is a writer's worse nightmare.
And being understood
is the greatest joy.
I wrote "Enchanted Air" at a time
when there was no public glimmer
of hope for renewed relations
between my parents' homelands.
During the same week when
advanced review copies arrived
on my doorstep, President
Obama announced the fall
in cold war hostility.
I promised I wouldn't cry.
I take it back.
[ Laughter ]
My childhood memories
written as a plea for peace
and reconciliation were
suddenly transformed
into a song of gratitude.
And I'll tell you why I wrote
them as a plea for peace
because I thought no U.S. President
would ever have the courage
to make peace with Cuba.
And I wrote it for children
because I thought, "Well,
maybe one of these
little people will grow up
and be courageous enough."
I hope it is a book that will
not just speak to Latinos
with their wide variety of
reasons for being able to visit,
Abuelita y los primos, but also
to readers from other backgrounds
who might feel like a bridge
or a storm for any reason.
But instead of the poem about
how I felt a bridge of the storm,
or a storm, I've decided to
read, "Refuge" on page 54
because we're in this
amazing library.
And this poem tells how
I came to be a writer.
We first took time right after my
family was interrogated by the FBI
for receiving phone calls and
mail from my grandmother in Cuba.
The ugliness of war
photos and the uncertainty
of TV news joined the memory of
FBI questions to make me feel
like climbing into my own secret
world, books are enchanted.
Books help me travel.
Books help me breathe.
When I climb a tree,
I take a book with me.
When I walk home from school, I
carry my own poems inside my mind
where no one else can
reach the words
that are entirely,
completely forever mine.
I hope Enchanted AIR might help to
inspire some young people to write
about their own lives and their
own feelings, and to find refuge.
When I was a teenager it was
easier for a U.S. citizen to walk
on the moon than to
visit relatives in Cuba.
Today it's not front page news
because peace is rarely celebrated
by the 21st century media, but
yesterday direct mail service
between Cuba and the U.S. resumed
after more than half a century.
And on Monday President Obama
will go to Havana [inaudible]
around a U.S. president
was courageous.
[ Applause ]
And I'm especially happy that
he's going to do ordinary things
in Havana, like attend
the baseball game
and treat a neighboring
country as a friend.
Thank you, Gracias,
y Gracias a Dios.
Thank you for this amazing honor
and for its perfect timing.
[ Applause ]
>> The next honoree is --
>> It's you.
[ Laughter ]
Here are [inaudible].
>> [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> This is the first Walter Award,
so we haven't worked everything out.
[ Laughter ]
The next honorees, they talk about a
fight that so many of us have grown
up knowing about, but
give us new perspectives.
There's the fight within someone,
you know, and for me growing up,
Malcolm was that paragon of
somebody who was brave enough
to fight with themselves.
There's one part towards the end
of the book where they give a list
of names, and this moment of saying,
"I need to choose my own name."
That is the biggest fight.
That is one of the fights that
we're excited to participate in.
And so we're very, very
honored to honor Kekla Magoon
and Ilyasah Shabazz for "X".
[ Applause ]
>> Kekla Magoon: Well, first
to Walter Dean Myers family.
God bless you.
He continues to inspire
me personally,
and I would imagine Ilyasah,
but she can speak for herself.
To We Need Diverse Books, God bless
you for even recognizing these books
and the importance of acknowledging
the diversity in our country.
I mean, this is the
melting pot of all nations.
To Candlewick, what a phenomenal
group of people to work with.
It's such an honor
to be in this place.
To be fellow, I don't know if you're
fellow, I mean, to the winners.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations.
You know, a long time
ago, I was in [inaudible]
with a lot of young girls.
And I said, "Hey, where
do you want to go?"
They wanted to go to Barnes &
Noble, when Barnes & Noble was big.
And so I said, "Okay.
Yeah." So we go to
Barnes & Noble and I said,
"Pick out whatever book you want."
And they brought these books
to me and I looked at them,
and I had young girls of color,
and it was very difficult for me
to buy a book for them because I
wanted them to open up the book
and see themselves in it, and have
a nice reflection of themselves.
And so I set out to
write a children's book.
And then my father's young journey,
his adolescent journey
was so misunderstood.
He came from a family of activists.
They instilled specific values
in him that he could grow up
and become this, you
know, great humanitarian
that would circle the globe, just
in his 30's, a very young man.
Circle the globe in his 60's searing
for solutions to the unit condition
that would want to afflict any
kind of trauma, psychological pain,
challenge to expel our brother just
because of this color in their skin.
So, you know, I thought that his
life was such an inspiration,
not only to myself and my
family, but to so many young men
in adolescence in that
they could read a book
and find themselves in it.
And that it would celebrate
their leadership,
their purpose, their lives.
And so I was so fortunate
and I searched high and low
for so many different co-writers.
And I came across this amazing
woman, this amazing sister,
and we were able to do, you know,
I think a pretty good
job, and well, obviously.
Right.
[ Laughter ]
With "X" the novel, I
think it's just, you know,
so important that our young
people recognize the power
that -- their individual power.
That they recognize
their leadership.
all of the things
that will help our country be
the best that it can possibly be.
So, I personally am so happy
and honored, and I thank you
so much for this [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> Ilyasah Shabazz: Hello.
I guess the first thing is,
thank you for choosing me
to work with you all on this.
It was so exciting to
have this opportunity,
and a little bit daunting to have
the opportunity to try to think
from the perspective of someone
like Malcolm X who has helped us
as a leader and a humanitarian,
and he's celebrated
and remembered 50 years
after his death.
And so that, you know, that task
is a little bit daunting, you know,
and quite an honor to be a part of.
One of the things we ran up
against in pitching the book
and selling the book
was the question of,
"Why do you need this story", right.
We all know Malcolm X's story,
but we don't all know Malcolm X's
story, which is another story.
But we know what happens, right?
We know how it turns out.
We know who he becomes, you
know, why do we need something
that looks inside his head
when he was a young man.
And, you know, where
is the suspense, right?
Where is the pretension, right,
in that story, because we know it
so well as a society in theory.
But one of the things
we talked a lot
about as we were working
was it's easy
to tell the story from
hindsight, right.
It's easy to look back and say, "Oh,
you know Malcolm X was
this great humanitarian.
He was perhaps destined to
be that, and we don't know."
But when he was 14 he had no idea,
right, who he was going to become.
He had no idea what
was next for him.
And he was making choices
based on the fact
that everything felt really
screwed up, everything was scary.
His family was being destroyed
by all sorts of things,
including institutional racism.
And he was up against things
he didn't understand and he had
to make choices in
that moment and in
that space not knowing
what was going to happen
for him and his life later.
And that, I think, is a
message that we really wanted
to be included in this book.
That every young person when you're
14, and everything is screwed up,
like that doesn't mean that that's
going to be the rest of your life.
You can make choices.
You have power.
You have the ability
to decide, "Okay.
This is what it is today and this
is what's tomorrow is going to be."
And so to be able to look at a story
about Malcolm for every young man
to look at, the choices that
he was making at that time,
but they're not the best
choices all the time, right.
And to say,"Okay.
Look at how he turned out, right.
What if I can do something?
What if I can decide tomorrow I'm
going to step up and be a person
who makes change in the world?"
That is something that, you know,
kids don't always hear, right,
that you have power, that
you can make choices,
that you can change your world.
And so, that was, you know,
what we hope readers
will take from the book.
And, you know, I hope that,
you know, people will continue
to read it and celebrate it
and learn more about him.
I hope it's a gateway for people
to learn about his life and work
and messages that he, you
know, spoke 50 years ago
that are extremely relevant to
our world today, unfortunately.
We definitely had an amazing
team working with us [inaudible].
Our editor, Andrea Compa
[phonetic] is brilliant as a reader,
and an editor ,and as a
colleague, and friend.
And our publicist Jamie Tan
[phonetic] has been amazing
at getting us exposure for the book
and getting us out into the world
to talk about it and share it.
And we love the cover of the book.
And so we want to give a little
shout out to Matt Roscher [phonetic]
who designed our book cover.
We get a lot of compliments on it.
It's pretty exciting.
But everyone at Candlewick worked
together to bring this book
to life and make it what it is.
And so we're really grateful to
be a part of that and to be here.
And thank you especially, of
course, to We Need Diverse Books
for honoring the book, for creating
this award, for allowing people
to have an opportunity to come
together to demand what we need
for readers, and to be a voice
for change because, you know,
it's not always one person.
It has to be a community
that comes together.
We look at the heroes.
We look at the Malcolm X's
and the Martin Luther King's,
the people who sit at the podium,
and that's not what's
interesting about what they did.
What's interesting about what they
did is how they inspired many,
many people to stand up.
And so we have that,
our work and the work
of We Need Diverse Books can
keep doing that for our children
and for readers everywhere.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> You know I just want to say,
sometimes when our young people are
in pain, right, they don't
make the best decisions.
And that's what happened
to my father.
He was in pain.
His father was gone,
his mother was gone.
His teacher told him that he was
an "N" word and there was no one
to say, "No, no, no, you're okay.
You're great."
We need the adults around us, right.
When we're in pain, we don't say,
"I'm going to go get
the best education."
Usually when we're in
pain, sometimes we say,
"I'm going to go have a drink.
I'm going to go smoke a cigarette.
I'm going to go do something
that's self-destructive."
So, I cannot say how important it
is that we need all of the adults,
all of us forward thinkers,
smart, beautiful adults
to really invest in
all of our children.
I cannot say that enough.
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> What Ilyasah says is so correct.
You know, with so many kids in pain
and there's this thing of like,
they have these fights inside them.
They have these arguments
going on about who they can be,
who they will be, who
they want to be.
And history has this
way of giving --
making the fights that go on
inside us happen outside of us.
These last few years, of course,
in the rise of Black Lives Matter,
we see a fight that is essential
to American identity happening
all across the country.
And I'm really excited and proud to
announce the winning Jason Reynolds
and Brendan Kiely for "All
American Boys" of the first Walter
that articulates that
fight in a very open way
on both sides of the equation.
This is a place full of fights.
This is a place full of
conversations and they have it
in a book, and gave that book to the
world, and we're very, very excited.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
>> All right.
>> Brendan Kiely: So, one thing
I've learned in our process together
that I didn't know before is
that I am Type A, and I have --
I have written down some
words from my journey.
[ Laughter ]
But so, I just want to -- I want
to say a few thanks and I want
to say a couple of words, especially
given the idea that I love this idea
that these books are fights.
And I really appreciate the
idea that we need to model
that fight for young people.
And I just really admire that.
And this is a tremendous honor
to be here with everyone.
And for "All American Boys" to
be recognized in the company
of these two powerful books,
to be part of the We Need
Diverse Books movement
that I admire very much.
For the book to garner
an award whose very name
and family fill this room
with a legacy of artistic
and socially conscious
vision and integrity.
This is truly humbling.
And a word like gratitude just
falls short of how I feel.
I want to thank the award committee,
the executive team,
and everyone at WNDB.
I almost said that.
But for the recognition
of this book.
Wow! I'm going to do it again, too.
And for the magnitude of the
work you all do everyday.
I also want to thank everyone
at SNS for the hard work it took
to put this book together and get
it out on shelves in record time.
And for all the work
that is still going
on to remind folks why
this book is important.
I especially want to thank
Justin Chandiff [phonetic]
for his eagerness to
make this book a reality
and Caitlyn Dewey [phonetic],
the third writer of this book
who saw the sculpture in
the stone and knew how
to guide our hands to get it there.
And most importantly, I want
to thank Jason for trusting me
and a friendship for which
I will forever be grateful
because as we always say,
"If the friendship is a bust,
then the whole book and
everything we fought for
and cared for is also a bust."
And "All American Boys"
is not a bust.
It is the single most important
thing I have been a part
of in my career, just
as your friendship is the
single most important friendship
in my career.
I say career because my final
thank you is to my wife,
Jessie Chafee [phonetic]
whose friendship
and love are the most
important in my life.
[ Laughter ]
But I'll just say this, that in
"All American Boys", at first Quinn,
the white boy, runs
away from the violence
or the injustice that he witnesses.
He runs away because as he
begins to process any of it,
he may have to make
significant changes in his life.
The system of law enforcement is
unjust, but how can those of us
who have the privilege to ignore
this ugly reality expect a system
that is unjust to change
if we don't make the leap
to make the necessary changes
we must make in ourselves?
This is one of the most dangerously
powerful aspects of privilege,
the privilege to look away,
to choose not to engage.
There's dangerous power in
choosing to not tell a story.
The reason we must say
Black Lives Matter,
and the reason we must
say it everyday,
is because there are already
too many missing people,
Tamir Rice [phonetic],
Sandra Bland, Michael Brown.
And we cannot let their
stories go missing, too.
We cannot.
And Quinn, a person of privilege,
must tell another part
of the story, too.
We cannot have an institution that's
systemically disenfranchises people
without also empowering others
to systematically benefit
from that injustice.
Or put another way, an
institution that historically
and systematically excludes some
voices, necessarily empowers others
to be systematically included,
or put more bluntly, published.
So, I say this with love
because I want to --
I want love to beat and hone in
my old, weathered, warn heart,
it's like an old Celtic skin drum.
That's my Irish background.
[ Laughter ]
And so I say this with
a spirit of trying
to call us in, not call us out.
Just as the statistics clearly
expose the injustice in the world
of law enforcement, the
numbers are starkly apparent
in book publishing, too.
We need more diverse --
a more diverse workforce.
A more diverse array of book
reviews and books reviewed.
And a much larger pool of diverse
authors getting published regularly.
WNDB and others are calling
for this institutional change
and we should all support them.
Institutions are made up of
individuals, many of whom are
like Quinn, like me,
people with privilege.
And I look to them
to partner with WNDB
and change their institutions
from within.
We cannot run away
or turn our heads,
or hope that someone
else will handle it.
It's on us, too.
White folk like me, straight folk
like me, able-bodied folks like me,
[inaudible] gendered folks like me.
This is how we join a powerful
movement WNDB is leading
in the industry.
We listen.
We partner and listen.
We listen some more and
then we get out there
and help make the change we
know in our hearts must come.
So, I thank everybody at WNDB for
this award, for the recognition
and support of all American boys,
and I thank them and cheer them
for their bravery, their
leadership, and their vision.
Thank you for pushing the world of
publishing to become its best self.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jason Reynolds:
So, it's interesting.
I've been thinking a lot
about, sort of, obviously,
about diversity leading
up to this award.
And usually when we talk about
diversity, we talk about sort
of what we see in the landscape.
When we look out into the
world, what do we see.
When we look onto our bookshelves
in this particular
context, what do we see?
But I feel like there's
another part of diversity
or even whenever we're thinking
about anything outside or ourselves,
I think it's always necessary
to take a moment to think
about [inaudible] ourselves.
And so I've been thinking a
lot about who I am lately,
perhaps this quarter life.
Some sort of quarter life
crisis thing happening.
But I've been really trying to
hash out, like who it is that I am.
What it is that I stand
for and what makes up me.
And I -- everyday I'm realizing
more and more that I am an amalgam
of the people that I've met.
That I'm an amalgam of the
experiences that I've had.
That I am, you know, pieces
of my mother, who is here.
And everybody who knows me knows,
you all know she's in the room
[ Applause ]
You know, pieces of my mother.
I mean, my mother, you know, she
gave me sort of the sense of pride,
both kinds of pride, you
know, the kind that sometimes
to a fault keeps me
from asking for help.
And the kind that allows me to
put my chest out a little bit
and hold my head up and walk the
earth like I'm God's child, right.
Walk the earth like
I'm Isabel's child.
And my father, who I don't
talk about much, you know,
I have pieces of him, you
know, his fearlessness.
A man in the 60's and
70's who was covered
in tattoos, which was unheard of.
A man who has always taken
his life by the reigns
and done whatever he wants to
do, whenever he wants to do it.
My best friend in the world
is here and I would be remiss
if I didn't say something to
him and he would let me know.
[ Laughter ]
My dear friend Ann Anisia
[phonetic] I've known for 30 years.
And I think about him
and how I'm amalgam.
And he's part of that
amalgam, you know.
A friendship for my entire life.
We are so different.
Two totally different people who
have forged a friendship based
on respect and love even as we've
grown into our individual selves,
not always seeing eye-to-eye,
but always connecting heart-to-heart
no matter what, forever and ever.
To my first husband --
[ Laughter ]
-- Brendan here.
I'm sorry, Jessie --
[ Laughter ]
to have to share him.
You know, but I tell people
all the time that, you know,
I come from a family,
especially my mother.
I come from a family, my
mother is from the south,
our household was rooted
and steep in our culture.
I'm very proud of that.
But it's an incredible experience
to work and stand next to a person
who is outside of that cultural
community and look at him and know
for a fact that he is the best
of what humanity has to offer.
It's a good thing.
Even my mother who in finding
out that I was writing this book
with him, and I'm going to
put your business out there.
[ Laughter ]
But he already knows.
The first thing she said
was, "Who is this guy?
What's going on?"
[ Laughter ]
The scars of the south heavy on her.
And then she started reading the
book and she called me and said,
"Now, let me get this straight,
did you write all of Rashad
and he wrote Quinn or did
he write some of Rashad?"
And I said, "No, I
wrote all of Rashad."
And she said, "Oh, okay, I
was getting ready to say,
ain't no way that he
could have known --
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Yeah, you know."
And then at the end of the book she
calls me and she says, "You know,
Jason, I'm just so
proud of Brendan."
Which is funny.
Which is funny in that she
didn't say she was proud of me.
[ Laughter ]
But it's powerful -
-- in the sense that she
came full circle, right.
Brendan was into the
circle of trust now.
I'm an amalgam of the
people that I've met
and the places that I've been.
I'm an amalgam of all
these young people that --
the young people that are locked
away in juvenile detention centers
that none of you ever
have to think about.
The ones who are doing 18, 19
year sentences at 15 years old.
The ones who come to me when I'm
there and ask me, "Mr. Jason,
they all keep telling
me I have to change.
They all keep telling me I have
to make different decisions
with my life.
But every decision I've ever made,
I've made because I thought
it was the right decision."
For the little girl in Philly.
When Brendan and I were in
Philadelphia, who came to me
and said, "Mr. Jason, has
there ever been a moment
where you just wish you could
change the color or your skin?"
She's there.
For the young lady in Germany
who I met two days ago who said,
"Mr. Jason, do you know
what it's like to know
that every single person in
the world when they think
of Germany they only
think of Hitler?"
And for me to in that moment
wish that that little girl
in Philly could know that
little girl in Germany
because they're the same.
They're experiencing the same thing.
I'm an amalgam of the
people that I've met.
You know, Chris Myers, my --
people know we have a
very tight relationship
and I'm grateful for him.
He's fueled my curiosity in a way
that not any human being has ever.
I've learned so much about refugee
boats and African billionaires,
and Vietnamese embroidery artists.
[ Laughter ]
I mean he knows everything.
Everything.
To the young people
that I met in Tucson.
To Michael Brown and his family.
I'm an amalgam of all
of these things.
And what I've learned after
thinking about all of this,
is I realized that the diversity
that we have to be discussing
as we discuss the diversity
that is existing on the outside,
is that there's also the fact that
we need to have as many stories
as possible to appeal to the
diversity on the inside of us,
each and every one
of us individually.
I am not [inaudible].
There isn't one kind of me.
I am all of the people, an
amalgam of the people that I've met
and the experiences that I've had.
My hope, and I know WNDB's hope,
is that I can write as many books
as I can, not for any solo book
to serve as some sort of mantle
for some young person, but so that
a collection of books can serve
as a metaphor for who they
are sliver by sliver, right.
That you can like all the
things and do all the things.
That you can like french fries
and really fancy restaurants.
That you can like to wear
a suit and Jordans, right.
That you can like the
south and the city.
And that that's okay.
So that someday when they're my age
they can look at their libraries,
they can look at their
collections, they've had a lifetime
with literacy, and they can say,
"All of these books are
the representation of me.
All of them."
No matter how different
they may seem.
Each and every one of
them has a portion of me.
That's my new purpose as of last
night thinking about these things.
My new goal --
[ Laughter ]
-- is to shift it a little bit.
So with that, I'd like
to say thank you to WNDB
for all of your hard work.
You guys have shown me an
insurmountable amount of love.
To the Library of Congress,
thanks for having us.
This is awesome.
And to the Committee,
thank you all very much.
To Caitlyn and Elena, these are --
Caitlyn is my editor
and Elena is my agent.
They're the ones who
get to see me the way
that only my family gets to see me.
The ones who know that most of
the time I'm extremely anxious.
I have terrible insecurities
around this work.
And they're the ones
who get to guide my hand
and believe in me regardless.
And to everyone else,
I just say thank you.
My mother needs to know that
as I move around the world,
there are people who got
me, people who love me.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Dhonielle Clayton.
>> Dhonielle Clayton: I took
a picture with Margarita.
We're going to have to reenact.
[ Laughter ]
We're getting better.
>> Margarita Engle:
It's pretty embarrassing
that I didn't know
there were [inaudible].
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> Christopher Myers: Um --
[ Laughter ]
I'm brought back to a day maybe
about four years ago when --
four or five years ago, Pop
and I would meet in the city
of [inaudible] most
Saturday's and go
to the flea market
and go through things.
And I had been wanting him
to meet Jason for a long time
because Jason was my boy and we
talked a lot about publishing
and wanting to see this -- to
make a space, to have these fights
that we had together in the world.
And at that point, Jason had
a job, a [inaudible] job.
[ Laughter ]
And I brought my Pop into the store
and my Pop in his kind of stiff,
but loving way said,
"Well, you know,
you're willing to do the work?"
You know, that kind of thing.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, I flash forward
to today, to this thing,
which I know he would
have laughed at.
He would be like, "What you
gonna call it, the Walter?"
[ Laughter ]
That didn't roll off the tongue.
I don't know if I need to be --
and I'm happy to see that
we're all here doing the work.
I'm happy to see how much
Jason is doing the work,
and Brendan is doing the
work, and Kekla, and Rita,
and Ilyasah, WNDB, the publishers.
We are doing the work.
We are having these fights.
We're having them respectfully
and lovingly and it's exciting
to be here doing the
work with you all.
And lastly, I'd like
to introduce John Cole,
someone who has been doing
the work for quite some time.
I remember I met you with
Pop about a 107 years ago.
[ Laughter ]
No, I'm 107.
You must be, I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
So, John Cole, the director
of the Library of Congress,
Center for the Book,
and chair of the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards
Program, and great advocate
of American letters and literature,
goodness in so many ways.
So, again, we thank you.
We thank you all for doing the
work, for having the fights,
for having them in a real way
so we can have these
discussions more and more.
I know that the next time I have
breakfast with Jason he's going
to say, "Man, you know I
killed that speech, right?"
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to be like,
"Yeah, you did.
You did." But I'm going to find
something to fight with him about.
[ Laughter ]
John Cole.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Well,
thank you, Chris.
I have been at the Library
of Congress a long time.
[ Laughter ]
Not quite 109 years, but I've
also written about the library
and I'm always looking for
wonderful new descriptions,
and now I have a new one,
the Library of Congress
is a prizefighting ring.
[ Laughter ]
A place for these fights to take
place that we're talking about.
We're very honored to be
able to be part of this.
And I have thank you's for all
of you for the work you're doing.
And I'm very pleased that through
the work of the Library of Congress,
particularly the Center for the
Book, and the Young Reader's Center,
which is part of the Center for the
Book, which was created in 2009.
It took us a long time.
It took us 100 years to figure
out, actually, that the Library
of Congress needed its own
place for young readers,
for dealing with people
under the age of 16.
One bit of history, when
this building opened in 1897,
this wonderful inspirational
building, it's wonderful
to have an inspirational program
in this wonderful building.
The first Librarian of
Congress had the idea
for a juvenile library
when this place opened.
He died after a year and a half.
He had nothing to do with this idea.
[ Laughter ]
But in the meantime, this
was 1897 the building opened,
John Russell Young died in 1899.
In the meantime, the District of
Colombia public library opened
and it's a wonderful place, but it
gave the next librarian an excuse
for not having a juvenile library.
And he said, "That's all taken
care of by the DC public library.
So long. I'm doing
my wonderful thing."
And it took 100 years,
until 2009, with the support
of Daniel Borsin [phonetic] --
James Billington [phonetic],
who is the Librarian of Congress to
create a special place for people 16
and under as long as they
had an adult with them,
which actually is a great advantage
because it makes us a
family literacy center
in this beautiful set of three
rooms, which I hope you've all seen,
in this beautiful building.
And that is a way that
we have been able
to use the Young Reader's Center
as a way to get into the fight,
to bring the Library of Congress and
the three sources that is prestige,
into the world of young
people's literature
in an absolutely direct way.
And what you've done, and what
we've done together with this award,
and with getting it launched
at the Library of Congress,
is helping the Library
of Congress in its fight.
Its fight to show that that young
people's literature is the world
that we should be involved in
directly and it makes sense,
and it would even make sense to
Thomas Jefferson, who had the idea
of opening the Library of
Congress, not just to Congress,
but to the nation so it
was available to everybody.
But the secret is, which
doesn't go in my history books,
it's the wrong side of the
statement, is we weren't open
to everyone, you had to be over 16.
And that started back when
we were in the Capitol.
So, we are together, part
of a history not only
for this wonderful world
of diversity that's coming
through publishing and writers,
but also for the Library
of Congress being a partner with
us is helping the broader cause
and really helping American
culture and literature
and its recognition be part
of this wonderful institution.
It is inspirational.
We now go to another
inspirational part of the Library
of Congress for our reception.
And I just want to mention
that as you walk down the hall,
our members room, we're going
to be in a very special room,
which is the one facing the Capitol,
and that's where the members
of Congress could come.
And it's really kind of a kick
because this side of the building --
first of all, the building is so
magnificent because it was built
between 1886 and 1897 when we
were flexing our cultural muscle,
and we wanted American
writers to be recognized.
We wanted to out Europe Europe
in the building, and we did,
but we also wanted to
honor American writers.
And so as you walk out into the
great hall, we're going to walk
down this hallway filled with muses.
So, the fancy, the gold is here
on the side facing Congress.
That's the way it was
in 1897 when we opened.
We're going to go down the
hall of the [inaudible].
Each hall has a different
them and field of knowledge.
And so the nine muses are
painted and there's poetry
by Alexander Pope in the hall.
Then we go through the great
reading -- the great main hall,
the great hall, and that's
where if you look up,
you'll see names of writers.
On the top, it's all
European and world writers,
you come down a level, you get
Henry Wadsworth Longfellow,
you get American historian,
George Bancroft.
And then the final stop before
we move into the Member's Room,
which is the most fancy room because
that was the members of Congress
and we're part of the legislative
branch, is the hall of poetry,
and there we really got
the tough part of the fight
that was probably going on
that we don't know about.
And instead of just an
occasional American, we split it
and half the poets in
the ceiling are European
and half of them are Americans.
And that's the only way I think that
Walt Whitman and Edgar Allan Poe got
into that ceiling because they were
not popular authors among the people
who built the Library of Congress,
and in that part of our culture.
Then we'll be in the Member's Room
and it's an inspirational room
for an inspirational day.
I congratulate the winners.
I'm so proud of the Library,
the Center for the Book,
for bringing this and combining
with you for this wonderful day.
And please let's enjoy ourselves
pretending like for a half a --
a couple -- an hour we're
members of Congress.
Thanks so much.
It's been a wonderful day.
[ Applause ]